Lesson number five.
I feel like oil futures are going to crash today.
What are the the gift back road now you try
next up producer Tim Howard. Yes. Hi. Hello.
So when I heard about this story with Emily and the brain port,
I immediately called up this guy. Hey John. Which microphone is it?
This one or this one or that one there? Okay. You might remember him.
I'm David Eagleman.
I'm a neuroscientist at Baylor College of medicine called him up because I came
across this thing that he's working on that is sort of like the next generation
of crazy. It's called uh, the vest,
which stands for the variable extra sensory sensory transducer.
And it's,
it's a vest that you wear underneath the clothing and this fest has 24 motors on
it. Little vibratory motors,
just like the ones in your cell phone and the vest connects to your phone.
So we pick ups.
Hi,
this is Time Warner cable calling with an opportunity for you to provide us with
valuable feedback
well through a cell phone and the cell phone does all the computational work to
then convert that sound into patterns of vibration
on the vest and you feel a buzzing all over your torso.
This is different motors running at different amplitudes.
It actually changes every 20 milliseconds.
So it's a moving pattern and it might seem impossible that you could actually
extract something useful about what's being said.
But when David brings deaf volunteers into the lab and has them do a particular
training on the vest, he says that over the course of 12 days,
people get really good at word recognition.
Somehow they begin to intuitively recognize that this means high or blue or
chair.
If you tried to concentrate on it and figure out how each motor translates to
some part of that sound, you would never figure it out.
But the good news is you don't have to do it consciously.
The brain is a specialist at extracting statistical information and because of
the Marine is so good at this kind of translation says David,
what he really wants to do is use this best to create new senses.
So what if you fed in stock market data
hockey 10 70 dash five nine 25 so 25 bucks,
75 bid at 78 converted that into
the buzzing.
Could you develop an immediate perceptual experience of the economic movements
of the planet and would you,
without having any conscious awareness of how or why you're feeling a certain
way, could you have an intuition like, you know,
I kinda feel like oil futures are going to crash today.
You wouldn't be analyzing all this information. You would just feel it.
We're also working on feeding in.
You are seeing a tremendous amount of rainfall and real time weather data
from the, let's say 200 miles around you question is,
would you end up having an intuition, Peekskill eyesore? Oh,
that's better than what the weather man can tell you on the news or this one.
What if we took 500,000 tweets per second,
passed it through some natural language processing to sort of have a,
a higher level summary of what's going on and pump all that information through
the vest.
Would you develop a sense of what's happening on the planet where you suddenly
say, Ooh, I feel like something just happened in Nairobi and, Oh,
I think the Canadians have just, you know, finalize their election,
have something in it. I don't know what this will be like yet,
but there's no reason to expect any limit on,
on what the brain will be able to develop an immediate perceptual experience.
Huh.
More experiments and translation in a moment.